hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast strain level microbiome
profiling using our RNA gene amplicons
presented by dr. mark driscoll chief
scientific officer co-founder shoreline
biome I am Keely Baca blabbers and I
will be your moderator for today's event
you're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
Birds labyrinth is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen type your
questions into the drop down box and
clicks it will answer as many questions
as we've time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Mark Driscoll I will now turn the
presentation over to him Thank You
Kaylee I really appreciate the
introduction I'd like to begin today by
thanking our collaborators and the
people who actually have done the work
that I'm going to talk about today our
collaborators at the Weinstock lab at
the Jackson labs for genomic medicine Bo
Yong Yong Zhao and Jethro we did a lot
of the analysis and Dan Phillips did the
heavy lifting at the bench we've
collaborated with Peter set low you'll
see some of George and Barbara's work
here on opening cells and tracking
microbes and getting the DNA out I would
also like to thank Dan for Sulu and
patterned genomics who has written a lot
of the software that's doing the
analysis healthy and at Shoreline biome
I'd like to thank Chris and Ryan for
so with that the microbial most people
in the audience will be familiar with
the microbiome but just to remind people
and get off on the right foot
I'd like to talk about why it's
interesting humans are in fact a
composite organism you have 10 times as
many microbial cells on and in your body
as you do human cells and it's
extraordinarily interesting to think
about that there's about a hundred times
the genetics going on inside so if you
want to find out about human health it's
going to help but either microbes and in
fact a lot of the work that's coming out
past few years is shown that microbes we
always knew they influenced digestion
and health that way but really
regulating the immune system
participating in the training of the
immune system development
and resistance to pathogens and they
inhabit all the spaces on your body and
protect you from invasion by organisms
and do everything from modulate your
bone mass density to health
so really microbes are expert in really
important in overall health and disease
and people want to study them but how do
you generate a microbial profile you
figure out which microbes are there and
what are they doing
so really microbial identification is
the key so this is what we want to do we
want to find out who's there and what
they're doing and I'll be talking today
about using the ribosomal RNA genes as a
microbial mugshot essentially I call it
that because what you're doing is you're
taking a look at a small portion of DNA
and you're attempting to identify the
organism that that came from oh so how
do people do this
what you want to do is target a gene
that every microbe has and in fact the
ribosomal RNA genes are in all of the
bacteria that are out there and so we
target this gene because we know
everybody's got it so the gene itself in
purple here are the parts of the gene
that are invariant
you can generate PCR targets ooh and
there are also nine variable regions
inside there which when you flank these
variable regions with PCR primers you
can read through with a sequencer and
then determine the sequence inside that
variable region and in down which
already does that belong that's
basically the upshot now the more
information you have the better your
accuracy is going to be and part of the
problem is that closely related
organisms often has very similar 16s
sequences so the more closely related
organisms can be difficult part I'm
going to discuss the time but in the
next slide what I want to show is that
this gene itself is interesting and that
it has a two-dimensional and
three-dimensional structure and the
ribosomes are interesting right because
the ribosome a transcription product is
actually directly forms the molecular
machine that makes proteins and so this
gene product will form a two-dimensional
folded structure shown on the left and
then that that is a spared and the
primer sequences that we target the
varying regions are you can see those
primer sequences will also reflect that
base pairs two-dimensional structure and
that in turn folds into on the right you
can see the three-dimensional structure
of the final 16s ribosomal RNA but the
two-dimensional structure is important
to think about because that's vital to
the functioning of the ribosome itself
and that's where our primer sequences
are going to be targeting a little more
on that a bit but for microbial
identification
since these similar organisms can have
similar 16s genes you can see in the
case here I've shown before different
Clostridium and they cause actually four
different kinds of disease and so it
would be very useful to know when you're
trying to identify organisms not just
that it's a Clostridium but that is the
cluster DM difficile in fact
we can do this with 16s and 23's jeans
but you require any a unique rather
unique amplicon design then I'm going to
discuss in a bit but not only is it
useful to know the genus and the species
of something like clustered named
difficile there are different strains
that are involved and some of these
strains can carry toxins and some of
them don't
so even if you have the species it could
be interesting to know what the screen
is because that can make the difference
great having the disease or not having
c-diff disease and so when you're
identifying organisms really if you
really want to get down into a strain
level we're going to have to have a
little bit of a different approach than
what we might have had in the past so in
the next slide I show that this is
possible or we at least have evidence
that this is possible about a quarter of
a century go follow Gertler published
his paper basically showing that for a
cluster in difficile and what is this
that you can tell the difference between
different strains by simply looking at a
combination of the 16s and 23's genes
now in the figure below the paper there
is a screenshot of part of the c diff
nap 11 genome and these circles cover
16s this small purple bar on the left
and the associated 23s genes they
usually come in a little machine
cassette like that and you can see on
the leftmost circle that there's a
little space between the 16s and 23
essence if you look in the one in the
middle if you look up just a little bit
you can see that there is a tRNA in that
piece of region and then on the third
cassette on the right you can see that
once again we're back to no Garen a in
there and so these are highly variable
even inside one organism and so what
Volker did back then was do a PCR
against the intervening sequence at
spacer region between the 23 s and 16s
gene and he look at the restore
an enzyme pattern and then using that
you could tell the difference between
the different strains we can do that
also with sequencing but to an even
higher degree of accuracy so in the next
slide I want to show what that actually
looks like so in the box right the right
of best match there is a read that is
mapped to the Z 31 chromosome and you
can see it matches pretty well so the
long purple bar is the 16s gene and then
there's a little space and then there is
a start of another purple bar which is
the 23s gene and you can see that our
gray that gray bar along the bottom of
that box actually is the sequencing read
and it crosses it covers the full 16s
gene and crosses through into the 23 s
gene and covers that spacer region now
if you go down to the partner mark next
best match what you can see is that same
read mapped to a slightly different seed
if genome and the bracket shows that
when you compare it to the read up top
or to the mapping up up that there is
some difference in this intervening
spacer region and then if you blow that
up a little bit follow the arrow over to
the right and the sequence down below
shows you where the insertions deletions
and speckies are I mean these two
different strains and so what we have
here is a practical example from
sequencing a read that matches the Z 31
see death train is very different or
different enough from the training 1071
that we can tell them apart so I just
wanted to show that this type of strain
level identification is possible but it
really depends on the amplicon you
choose and so in this slide we see the
in the center you can see that familiar
purple and gold with a v1 v2 v3 and then
that's the 16s gene and then
the internally transcribed spacer in
pink and then to the right it started
over 23 s gene so this shows you where
our various amplicons that I'll be
discussing are placed you can see the v4
amplicon which is in the v1 v3 amplicon
which are 292 and 526 paces respectively
and these are typically sequence using
Illumina technology i below is the about
1500 V 1 V 9 and amplicon the purple box
and then there is a darker blue box with
the what I'm gonna call the ext amplicon
which is 2455 basis long and it spans
the full 16s gene the I TS and the 23 s
between a part of the 23's gene that you
saw the example of the read up above but
the take-home message from this part is
I really wanted to demonstrate first off
that it's not unreasonable to assume
that the ribosomal RNA gene sequence
information can be used to differentiate
between microbial strains so with that
said we're going to get into sequencing
that actually does this and and the
approach for that so there are a number
of challenges when you start a project
like this and really what you want to do
I think the best thing is to begin with
the end in mind what do you want out of
the experiment so what are the tasks
that are going to have to get done or
accomplished to get to a result that
you're looking for first of all you got
to get the DNA
license and DNA preparation it's been
known for a long time in this field that
the way you crack the cells is crucial
to the results back in amplicon
selection we discussed a little bit of
that just a minute ago depending on
where the amplicon is and how much
information it carries you can get
better or worse identification at the
family genus species or even strain
level depending on what you select
primer design now this is something I
showed that there were conserved regions
in the 16s gene there are also concerned
regions in the 23's gene they're
conserved but not fully considered so
certain families or organisms may have
slight differences between them and you
want to cover all of the variability but
you can capture all of those organisms
and all of its custom unique ways that
we have to do that
and then finally analysis you can have
the greatest sequence data in the world
but if you're tossing all that up
against the database that doesn't
contain the organisms that you have or
doesn't have the read length to
distinguish them you're only going to
get a results as good as your database
so we'll take all these in turn in the
next few minutes
so first lysis and DNA preparation
really the upshot is if you don't get
the DNA out of the cells you're not
gonna get any sequence data and this is
a harder problem than at first I imagine
did point B when we took this on you
think hey this is salt this is not
solved and the microbiome presents a
unique opportunity and problem in this
area because if you're just lacing a
Vatika coli you know who cares if your
licenses you're gonna get enough plasmid
DNA out but in this case really since
you're scanning a diverse population and
some of the most interesting bugs are
the hardest crack so if you're looking
at gram-positive firmicutes and you're
looking at Clostridium they can be
really difficult to open and so if you
if you have a license and DNA recovery
technique that doesn't open up bugs
sometimes these are the most interesting
ones and you're they'll be missing or
greatly diminished in your final data
set so you want to have a lysis that
will crack the bugs and really I on the
left you have reality where you have a
very diverse array of organisms and then
on the right typically what you see with
what we've seen with most kids is that
you're simply missing or greatly
diminishing some of the more important
organisms now the hard part is that
boring ones they show up really easy
little interesting ones can be a real
problem so we set out to address this
challenge and this is really where we
meet it gains what I'm showing here is
five different
fecal samples so these are actual
real-life eco samples that were prepared
with our rapid prep versus out there for
this and really I what we're looking at
is the orange bar when we compare
samples one two three four and five and
the size of that orange bar relative to
the rest of the microbes and what you
can see is that in the rapid prep
compared to the standard prep in almost
every case you see a lot more of a
Firmicutes per gram positive ones
but once with the tough cell walls
coming out so this is really the meaning
of this but of course you want to want
to validate this and make sure that it's
actually true in one of the indicators
early on is if you take a look at a
sample example for you can see that
there wasn't a big change and so it's
not uniform and it depends on the
proportion of bacteria in the sample
that are difficult to lyse so if you
have a large proportion that are
difficult place you'll get a sample that
looks like number five where with the
standard prep you get a few of them and
then what that microbial really looks
like is that it is the majority
difficult to lace organisms if they're
relatively easy all easy to lace you'll
get a sample it looks like four and then
typically what we see is something that
looks like one or two or three where
we're seeing more firmicutes
pop up with our rapid lysis method than
with the standard methods but it dig a
little bit deeper in that you'll think
that hey if there are more of these
Firmicutes appearing you get more from
the acute species with the improved
lysis so the answer to that is yes kind
of so you get more of the really
difficult ones so the cluster D I'm
showing up top those two the bloody ax
and the address those two guys what you
see for most of the samples that we ran
is that they're heavily underrepresented
in the standard prep and the
representation goes way up with the
shoreline pile rapid that's especially
true with with the address and
microbes of that type I but there are a
number of them like streptococcus that
are equally represented and regardless
of the method and that's exactly what
you'd expect easily laced organisms
should appear in both lysis techniques
and they do now the next question is how
do we know relating everything and
that's a real problem because how do you
ever know you're getting everything so
the way we decided to tackle this was to
put together a completely independent
placeis technique but what I've been
talking about is chemical the one I'm
about to talk about is physical and we
figured that if we have a chemical
technique on one hand and a physical
technique on the other hand and they can
give you the same results chances are
you're looking at most of the microbes
and the catch with the physical is that
we wanted to be able to recover spores
why spores spores are really hard to
crack open without destroying the DNA
many of the methods that you can use to
completely destroy regular cells don't
even touch spores and that was the case
in this case and this is where our
collaborator with collaboration with dr.
settlers lab came in
he's been cracking spores for years and
so essentially we came up with a
mechanical method for treating cells
that would crack the spores but not harm
the DNA and it's something that it's a
unique little machine that has a quite a
unique action to it it's a we applied
for a patent on but essentially what we
can do is in just a few seconds we can
crack open spores and if we get spores
then we get every other vegetative cell
or so we think
but we can also keep the DNA intact
which is the key because a lot of
beading methods or mechanical methods
when you do enough damage to the spores
to get the DNA out you've destroyed the
DNA of the other cells that are in there
so we know from experiments we've done
that we can quickly release the DNA and
it's intact and in the grey graph on
left essentially what you're looking at
on the left is
taxes per VM fluorescence which is a
surrogate for a DPA which is a chemical
that it is packed around the DNA inside
the spore head and so we know we're
tracking spores when DPA is released and
then we can look for the DNA because we
can release the DPA but if the DNA is
shredded beyond all repair than more
trouble but what we can find is that
even with extended treatments in this
method and we get high-quality DNA that
is trapped in the wells it's high
molecular weight with your honor leather
gel and we cracked the spores in just a
few seconds so we know we have a chem of
a chemical method that does pretty well
and how does it compare to this
mechanical method which is suitable for
holding spores
that's what you see on the right hand
side is the same samples done with the
rapid prep which we just went through
before a chemical method and then the
beating prep which I just talked about
here which cracked spores and what you
can see in sample after sample is that
the results are pretty much the same and
that's looking at the phylum level so
that's a pretty free and thousand foot
view but if you zoom in and take a look
at the species screen level you can see
that once again you're picking up the
same organisms at about the same ratios
whether you're using the mechanical
method or the chemical method and so
this says to us we've got two completely
independent methods of cracking open
bogs that give us a whole lot of
Firmicutes and clostridia which are the
tougher ones we know one of these will
give us DNA from scores and they both
produce the same results from the table
so we're pretty confident that we've got
a pretty valid way cracking spores
cracking cells and getting the TMAO so
the conclusions on this is that your
results start with cracking open the
cells and if you don't lyse it you're
not going to sequence it so we came up
with a few methods that enable us to get
the same answer regardless of how we
crack the cells and recover the DNA and
if you're doing an experiment of this
type it is externally useful to have two
independent methods of recovering DNA
that yields the same
answer so that's really where I want to
move on from lysis and move to the
second challenge which is amplicon
selection read links versus read
quantity so essentially the longer reads
will give you more information but
they're gonna cost you only so what is
that balance and so going back to this
slide where I discussed the common
amplicons the 292 d4 very common frame
look on amplicons being sequence using
aluminum and for v1 v3 it's a little bit
longer a little bit less common but very
powerful for getting more information
out and that's one 500 and the those are
both Illumina if you look down below we
have the V 1 V 9 in the purple box which
covers the entire 16s gene more
information than you get typically with
either the shorter amplicons but still
difficult to tell
spraying level organisms art and then
down below that we have the EFT amplicon
the dark blue bar with the white
lettering and that's around 2500 bases
and those those longer amplicons are
typically sequenced using a pack bio
platform and that's the some of the data
that I'll be showing you and that's
where some of the more interesting
results are coming so I want to focus on
that so what does it look like just to
remind you here's another example of a
c-diff where we map a read that came
from a strain of c diff to a reference
that's from a different strain and you
can see in this one once again that gray
bar all over the 16s purple bar and that
yields a map that actually contains a
gap in this case and exchange it's
sufficient to tell the difference
between the two strings so we know once
again here's another example of the
ability to get strain level information
about clustering difficile and we're
using this as an example and therefore
the reasons for now
going to in a minute but the trade-off
so I like I mentioned if you're going to
sequence using alumina you're gonna get
a whole lot of reads for your money and
you can cram in 300 me for samples or
more in a run and you're gonna get a
good sequence data for those v4 or v1 v3
or other shorthand LeConte
if you really want an experiment it's
going to nail things down at the
screening level you're going to need
longer amplicons
and we PacBio is the way to do that the
sequel instrument that is some of the
data that i'll be talking about with you
today you can put in about a hundred
samples on that and get fair levels of
pretty good levels of information out so
that's what I'll be talking about mostly
down below the next challenge primer
design so structure and function are
related and this is just something I
want to take on for a minute because
remember in the beginning when I showed
the 16s ribosomal RNA sequence linear
and the 2d structure and in the 3d
structure when you choose a primer
that's in a conserved part of this
ribosomal RNA gene which you're
essentially doing is choosing something
that is an important structure because
any changes to that sequence will change
the structure any change that structure
will make the the ribosomal RNA
non-functional and therefore the
organism won't survive so in the upper
right hand corner there's that little
hairpin that I've put together and that
is a representation of primer 27 forward
site which is in the v1 region and I
forms this hairpin loop structure that
you can see now the purple bases are
completely conserved if you take a look
at the still the database and you take a
look at all the available 27 have
sequences you'll see that these are in
varying it across all your database of
likewise with the rakin genome database
so those don't move around very much but
bases in black do change and the changes
that are in the RIKEN database and in
Sola Database are indicated by the
generate letters for the nucleotide
search on there and you can see that it
funds this little structure and so is
the canonical sequence for the 27
forward primer is shown right below it
is the in little lead letters as shown
in the same sequence with the degenerate
primers thrown in there and if you were
to take all the potential degeneres
primers that you can make with those
base substitutions you can get 384
different primers if you're designing in
PCR this is a pretty inefficient thing
you don't want to have a 384 primers in
there so we took a look and say hey how
many of those 384 are important like for
instance how many of them actually exist
in which organisms and maybe we could
sort of thing it turns out that if you
start really looking hard at this
there's only 17 allowed variant within
all of that 300 or basic aids though we
were able to cover all organisms in the
wreckin database and all organisms that
contain this sequence in the till the
database with only 17 different primers
and so this suddenly becomes tractable
you can design a PCR that's got 27
that's got 17 generate primers in there
and why would we want to do this well we
know that there is variation and from
organism to organism and that even a
two-base difference in the primer
sequence can illuminate the
representation of certain microbes and
in addition the surgery revealed that
there isn't any Polish primer pool that
covers all the known organisms that are
so what we did was we went back in
design primer sets but not all the
variants for the relevant primer
sequences that I've been talking about
so down below in the lower right you can
see where the 2d structure sort of melds
into a 3d ish structure or base pairing
between different parts of the 16s gene
why those changes may be linked in to
two other changes inside the ribosomal
RNA team in addition to designing for
the known variants because we know we
need to maintain this structure and
these base pairs so within the 16s gene
we can also potentially design for
variants that we haven't found yet so
you can look at this and say what would
the base thing is that would be allowed
it would still maintain these structural
relationships and incorporate those as
well so it's a very interesting set of
findings so that's primer design now I
want to talk a little bit of a marketing
scheme what are the barcodes well the
barcodes are little DNA snippets that
are attached to each sample so that we
can sequence them all together that
makes things ask effective but then
later on we can leave those barcodes and
then research all of those and so
there's a couple of different methods
that are out there
one is combinatorial and it's really
published one by McConnell and all are
this unique dual matched and really the
difference is that on the left that
little figure down below the little
colorful figures combinatorial you're
using across each column and row you're
using a single barcode so if you look
down in the first column you can see
that the top half of the typical black
and if you look at the top low you can
see the bottom half of each of the
circles is white and it's the
combination of the two that tells you
which sample he originally came from so
those are a tax during sample prep and
then they're mixed together in sequence
together and then we read the sequence
to sort them later with the unique dual
gnashed it's a little bit different in
that every sample has two unique
barcodes the front and one on the back
and so if you read it to assign a sample
to a well you have to get both barcodes
correct and so the chances of miss
assigning a read
are much lower when you have to
cross-check barcode as opposed to just
one so the problem is that the
combinatorial is simple and cheap to do
and the unique dual Nash is much more
expensive so depending on the degree of
accuracy you need for your experiment
you don't want to take on one or the
other so that is bar coding and then I
want to move into analysis so analysis I
even if you have the best data it's not
going to necessarily get you this kind
of result where those who are familiar
with mother will recognize that kind of
the output you get on across the top you
can see that there's the axon and temple
1 and sample 2 in this case and then for
each tax on it tells you what the with
them like what the microbe is and so in
this case we've got a high degree of
long we've got extra long reads here so
we can map down to the strain level this
is a database that we put together a
shoreline we're calling it ena and it
contains these linked 16 s 23 as gene
cassettes so when we map long reads we
can get the kind of accuracy that we
would want to have that strain level and
so now I'll get into I continue this but
I'll get into why are we using cluster
team difficile as an example because
there's a whole lot of sequencing that's
been done and it's relatively simple to
validate that we're getting the correct
answer here so if you take a look the
taxonomy of clustering difficile is
shown in red across the levels access
from family down to unit species and
inside the cluster deity's difficile is
912 different genomes that have been
sequenced to one degree or other and
around the outside of that taxonomic
tree that's circled down there you can
see I've put in black where the fully
sequenced genomes are on the taxonomic
tree and so it gives us a lot
of known diversity that's really heavily
sequent so we can tell are we getting
the right answer or the wrong answer
because there's a lot of data here so
when we take a sample that contains
c.difficile we should be a little to
sort out which it strains of c-diff or
in that sample and that's what I'm going
to show you in the next slide
though your database for each of these
three different databases we map to the
ribosomal protein database Silva and
Athena which is the shoreline biome
database we essentially took the same
data sets with the c.difficile reads and
we map them against these databases to
see what it would produce and so the
shorter reads that are in the RDP and
Silva databases really they will get us
down to cluster do so it's some kind of
Clostridium and and that's great I mean
if that's what you need out of the
experiment that's fantastic in this case
though what we wanted to do is get down
to the strain level and why you want to
do that is evidence by this particular
sample because number one there's five
different strains of seed if that
individual is co-infected with they were
a it was at a very low level in fact
this was a sample that came back as
negative when in fact real detects
positive and what we're able to show is
that there is the presence of this seed
of Z 31 in there which is a non-toxic
antek strain that is how the disease
causing toxins in it but it's you know
it's also Co evident with a number of
strains that are just plain bad news so
this kind of thing and tells you that
even after at the genus species level
you have seed if there are different
strains of seed if that may have
different different effects so if you're
if you're you're inhabited with C 2 C 31
it doesn't have the toxin and you
probably not going to get the disease
the other ones yes you will
so having the database that has these
longer gene cassettes and it enables us
to real
get down to the strain level item which
is great and so what we're gonna do
though is this was a really well
sequenced example there's a lot of
c.difficile
you know ones out there what about other
you know it's can we
organisms and we generalize to other
organisms and I think the answer to that
is yes because I if you take a look at
this we knew that the organism was
supposed to could be there and even
though it tested negative the person had
something allowed and so we detected
this at low levels at one point four
percent and were able to get five
strains of specific information out and
anything that wasn't assigned as a
strain was also assigned as though what
we know we can do is because of these
Lonnie amplicons that we've got to cover
this and finally train five spacer into
the pre s gene we can actually even take
unknowns and and categorize them as well
because you might not know what it is
but you've got enough sequence
information to know that it's not
anything that's been sequenced before
and so if that's an important organism
to you you can follow it track it in it
and potentially even see what it if it's
interesting enough so what do you get
when you put it all together on the
right hand side what I'm showing is a
short amplicon with technique and what
you can see is that for some of these
samples the first sample on the left and
the third from the right
it doesn't look very interesting but if
you combine the optimized lysis and
you've got a long amplicon and you've
got a good database what you can do is
you can take a look at sample number one
on the left with a long amplicon from
lysis and you can see that that's far
more interesting that it first appeared
there's actually very little of that
sort of gold boring Bacteroides in there
and it's mostly made up of other
organisms that would be experimental
interesting tracked down
once again beginning with the end in
mind the experiment looks very different
at the end depending on the choices that
you made at the beginning going in and
so the analysis the effect of the
analysis or the outcome of the Alice is
very different that's really putting it
all together and just to come back to
what the challenges were and so theory
it's important for laces of DA
preparation if you don't get the DNA
simply not gonna show up your amplicon
selection is important depending on how
far you want to get down there your
primer design are you gonna cover all
lose my clothes right those in certain
sequences aren't necessarily fully
conserved so you've got to put some
degeneracy in there and then for your
analysis your analysis in this case can
be as good as the database that you're
using so it's important to consider that
when you are putting your experiment
together how are you actually going to
take a look at these reads when you're
done and then what I want to do is just
talk about reasons we are taking this on
at Shoreline is because we wanted to put
together a process and a kit that would
cover all of these issues and put it in
something that you could just put your
sample in have all this taken care of
choose your amplicon and have it come
out and if you are interested in this
and finding out a little bit more you
can shoot me an email there's an email
associated with the talk today but also
you can feel free to send an email to
lab boots at Shoreline ion comm to me
mark with any comments and questions and
with that I'll be glad to take questions
thank you dr. Driscoll for that per
minute presentation we will now start
the live Q&A portion of the webinar you
have a question you'd like to ask please
do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation would type
your question into the box that appears
on your screen and click the send button
well answer as many
as we have time for let's get started
our first question is you spend a lot of
time on lysis methods I thought there
were microbiome specific kits and
protocols available that already solved
this problem yeah that's that that's a
great point we thought the exact same
thing until we really got into this I
was really convinced that the lysis
probable to solve some of the very first
experiments we ran we saw that this
actually isn't the case and that we were
saying a lot of the really important
Firmicutes that we really wanted to find
out information about so we tried a wide
variety of different kits those results
are currently eating collated and
published or been it be submitted for
publication very soon and so we should
see some more information out there
about this there's a number of
publications that I didn't direct the
reference better in the presentation it
talked a little bit about the laces
problem where the missing firmicutes
problem so it's something that's it's
known I think people have been working
around it and we tried our best to
actually solve it great thank you
another question we have is you cover
the known microbial diversity you
discuss using degenerate primer PCR and
your 16s microbiome acids however the
ratios of degenerate primers can
introduce a new kind of bias based on
relative to generate primary
concentrations do you address this and
if so how yeah that's something that we
struggled with a bit because as you
introduce degenerate primers as I was
talking about you can get up to you know
it looks like you've got to add in some
cases 384 primers to cover the
degeneracy but when we really dug into
this I addressed a little bit in the
talk about how we can cover all known
diversity with far less primers but but
even now even having as few as 17
primers in the
can result in primer the primer bias so
what we've done is we've come up with a
unique PCR approach that addresses this
we're in the beginning the PCR amplify
our developed by specific primers but
then as the reaction proceeds it's sort
of a nonspecific PCR reaction takes over
and to amplify I bring to the end of the
reaction while maintaining the ratios in
the beginning so in that way we're able
to avoid most of the primer diversity
bias that comes from having a lot of
different primers in there it's
something we're going to be publishing
under a soon so stay tuned alright and
we have time for one more question and
this one says it seems like a lot of the
field is moving towards shotgun
microbiome sequencing but your
presentation is focused on 16s can you
comment on the relative merits of 16s
versus shotgun approaches why keep using
16s yeah that's that's something that's
known they there's a trade-off I with
16s just simply because you need a lot
less sequencing so with the shotgun
microbiome sequencing there's hundreds
to thousands of times more sequencing
information you need to get the same
thing and it's the same result so you
can do a lot fewer samples that way
which is which is kind of an impediment
the other issue was really are we
covering everything and that's something
that I think we're able to address more
or less with our primary diversity we're
recovering everything that's been
sequenced and we're potentially it will
recover things that even that haven't
yet so there's that as to why you want
to continue doing this in expensive
nature and improvements to the diversity
output really the issue is also with the
database as I discussed at the end the
database
that you're comparing to and mapping to
really allows you to identify what
organisms are in there and some of the
experiments that we've done with the
shotgun even the best databases for that
we know we put in only ten organisms and
a few hundred come out so we know
there's a huge disconnect in there as to
how do you assign what which organisms
are present and so that that's a problem
that in the whole genome sequencing
shotgun microbial it's gonna have to be
better addressed I think so there was a
number of reasons but really it's once
again getting back to you know what do
you want out of the experiment if you
want to identify the microbes sort of a
fast cheap way to do it is 16s still
I would like to once again thank
director skal for his presentation I
would also like to thank Bob Ritz for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through August 2018 you will receive an
email from lab earning you know when
this webcast will be available for
replay be sure that announcement with
your colleagues and who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon goodbye